hello and welcome to the first code
technologies podcast
i'm really happy to announce my first
guest a storage engineer or
infrastructure engineer and a good
friend of mine who i've known for a long
time
mr josh brandon now a little about josh
he's kind of a
little bit of a private guy like i asked
him if he wanted to
or he wanted me to promote anything of
his or anything like that or
shout out his twitter or youtube channel
and he was like no the internet could
just leave me alone that'd be fine
so just keep that in mind but uh he's
someone that's been a member of uh like
my friend group someone i've known since
college and even a little bit in high
school
and he is uh you know someone when he
jumps in the group
joins the group you just know you're in
for a laugh because he is just a
hilarious guy
and a great sense of humor great
storyteller and i don't want to talk him
up so much that
it's going to disappoint or something
but also you should know he's someone
that goes against the grain
he's someone that's always kind of been
there for me someone that will set me
straight when i'm out of line
someone with a high moral compass uh so
to speak
but in a in a different sort of way like
you know josh is always looking out for
the little guy
or looking out for the person who might
be unthought of or left behind or
or something like that he's always
trying to help his friends in need and
and people in need so
i see that in him but uh he can come off
a bit
harsh sometimes because also he's not
afraid to just kind of lay it out there
when it needs laid out
so also a few other quick notes on kind
of the
quality of how things turned out so
turns out when you're
trying to use your webcam in obs
and in discord at the same time it
doesn't doesn't really work so well so i
had to do this virtual cam thing and it
got
it was a little awkward but we had to
make do we also shot over the course of
two days
and there were a few audio issues so
what do you know the first episode
working out the king say it just uh had
to do
what i had to do so i tried to fix some
of that in post but i also wanted to
leave it largely unedited
and uh you know it's it's not perfect
there's always
and things like this when they're live
and recorded you're there's always
something where you're like man i should
have said that different
and stuff like that but overall it's in
there it is what it is
i think it turned out pretty well
overall and
i'm happy with it even though
i realize i could have asked better
questions or responded better or
maybe even i said a few things that i
don't entirely agree with but you know
in the moment things just come out
so you know he's basically
rose the ranks in his field by being a
great guy
and being pretty good at his craft and
studying hard so i think there's a lot
to learn from this conversation
and uh just a lot of great moments so
yeah just really happy to have josh on
for this first podcast really happy he
accepted
and uh yeah let's get into it but first
i do have a sponsor so check him out
introducing
so what is zeet well if you take a look
at their page
link down below click the link
check it out so basically what they do
is they help you run your software on a
server
and then scale it to whatever your need
may be
so if we just take a quick look here we
can get some some hot takes
z is the best place to deploy any
software
start by instantly deploying to our
managed cloud and then scale to millions
of users
without breaking a sweat
they offer things like a seamless
workflow no install needed
just push to github and it triggers a
new build
they offer magic detect z will read your
code and figure out what its
requirements are
every language and framework bring your
favorite stack
they work with pretty much whatever
you're using
all you have to do is build scale and
monitor
so definitely check them out down below
consider
renting a server from them it's actually
really easy
to deploy you can click this get a demo
button
and get a nice rundown
of how it goes there's an examples tab
where you can see
some examples of running things there's
docs they have a
their own discord and they're pretty
active
and also if we click to start you can
jump right into it
you can log in with your github or
connect with your github
deploy your docker image and get started
so click the link down below
help support this podcast you can also
support
code tech tutorials on patreon or just
by hitting the like button
without further ado
here we go i guess
the goal of this is basically to kind of
like
for young people or people that aren't
familiar with your field to
kind of get understanding of of what you
do and
what they might need to aspire to learn
to kind of get in to a position like
yours and also just like
the life lessons and and just other
little stuff
so it's it's a little bit loose
but the goal is kind of for learning
um and
i have some things written down here
like
like maybe we should talk a little bit
about our background
and and just kind of let people know
that like we've been friends for a long
time so
it's not like it's not like this is new
to us we could we could sit and chat for
hours about life or whatever
and it'd be all fun
but what i think's really interesting is
kind of your story that's kind of
the reason i asked you to if you wanted
to come on
because i know that like
you went through some trials and you
kind of
built yourself itself up to a place that
you know a lot of people can't get to
basically
so maybe we could talk a little bit
about that first
if if you're up to it sure so
it's already interrupt but just like any
of these questions if you if you don't
want to talk about them or whatever
that's fine
we can always just move on something
else i think given the time that we have
left
uh we could probably nail like my
background
with the time that we've got left
because you said you got a hard stop at
four and now i do as well i didn't
before
now i do okay so we could
certainly do the uh the background first
let me turn you up just a little bit
mic check yeah it's a little bit better
i'll probably have to turn it up tiny
bit post but that's okay
so yeah like uh
i don't know like me i guess i've told
my story a little bit on my channel
about how
like uh i was into fry for a while and
we were in devry together
and we kind of both had the same
conclusion of this the school isn't for
us so we both
kind of quit at the same time and then
we also kind of had the unique thing of
we both ended up working at a college
without a college degree which is sort
of a
paradox yeah so maybe
like some people probably heard my story
or they could go back and watch my video
and see it but
but what about yours
so
[Applause]
the thing kind of the the opening
capstone point for me was always
try to be good to people no matter where
you're at in life
because generally it can come back and
help you
now not always but sometimes my story
is full of examples of where
my relationships with people actually
got me to the next step in my journey um
so yeah um started at about 15
um i had a computer and it broke it was
a hand-me-down for my grandma
it was running windows 3.0
and uh i i wasn't allowed to get another
one we didn't have the money for it
so i'm like well [ __ ] it i could
if it's broke i'll try to fix it so i
opened up the side case and
you know there's ribbon cables
everywhere because this is way before
ssds and
sata drives and all that fun stuff
floppy drives
oh those days yeah so i get in there and
i get me
some tape and i just i make tape on all
the cables and i record like this goes
to here
this goes to there and i try to
understand it i take the whole damn
thing apart
and then i put it back together and it
still didn't work
not even close i probably even put it
together wrong i don't remember
but i thought it was really fun it's
kind of like legos meets uh
erector set meets like computer-y
nonsense
so i went to a library and i got a book
and started reading about
computers so this was kind of like the
your origin of messing with computers
was that yeah
that 3.0 old thing that didn't quite
work right
oh yeah um i still didn't have a
computer at this point but my neighbor
did so i would go over to his house and
play games
well then we got a computer and it was
old i think it was windows 95
at this point and we were trying to
figure out how to copy games from his
computer to my computer
he had a game called entertainment pack
4 which is just like a myriad of
cheap crappy games and i really wanted
it but i didn't have any money
so what we tried to do was copy the
shortcut on his desktop
to a floppy disk and take it over
and i moved it to my computer and of
course it didn't work right
so the driver here is failure
it doesn't work but you want it to work
so you try to
figure out why it doesn't work right and
at the time you're
just a kid no experience so
i don't it might maybe we should clarify
like what what you do now
now this is let's see 25 years later
um i run all of the frank uh franklin
university
virtualization storage backup and
disaster recovery platforms
i am basically an infrastructure
engineer the network team
is like one layer in the stack below me
and then the operating system teams are
the the team that's a stack above me
i i manage hypervisors and all of the
machines
i make sure they're on i make sure
they're protected if they blow up i make
sure we can get them back
and if our entire data center blows up i
make sure we can recover somewhere else
wow that's what i do in a nutshell
that's
it's it's really interesting to hear the
just like the difference of going from
the origin story of
trying to figure out how to copy a file
to now
just managing all of that
interestingly the process
is more complicated but the the core
challenges i face are very similar
i never have enough money to buy the
things that i want like the tools that i
want to do a good job
so a lot of the time it's like well how
can i reverse engineer this
and and make it work in a way that is
stable
and secure and safe and legal
but on the cheap so a lot of that is
writing my own scripts to automate
things
that i would otherwise have to do
manually because we refused to buy a
tool that would do it for me
so it's the same it's the same idea it's
just
a different day a little bit older i see
and to clarify you do have you do now
have degree but at the time when you
first got this job
you didn't have a degree i did not um
i did the same thing kind of you did
where
we were in devry and if i moved really
fast and i'm not bashing devry this was
just
18 19 year old josh this is where i was
they kind of fed you through a fire hose
on like this is a subject
learn yeah we all felt that too
we also had an hour commute there and
back every day so like
a lot of our life was just school and
homework
and sleep like that was it
and then we started to figure out that
like maybe we don't have to do just
school homework and sleep maybe we can
play magic in the cafeteria instead and
hang out with our friends
that's real fun oh good times i i do
believe that me
and to a lesser degree you are probably
responsible for about half of our gaming
group at devry not graduating
it's entirely possible
but uh i end up dropping out of devry
i actually dropped out of devry three
times
um dropped out went back a little later
dropped out again
and then some time passed you know i got
into the working force
went back a third time and i was just
like yeah i don't really want to do this
that's where i was at i i remember
basically just failing a couple classes
not because i couldn't do them i just
literally wasn't showing up because i
wasn't interested
yeah and yeah that's kind of how it
struck me too and i always remember
like see and you know you see
i had never been to like a dorm or a
tradition more traditional college but
i kind of had seen what it would be like
and i was like why didn't i choose that
that looks a lot better
yeah it i remember in our high school
the devry rep
showed up and was basically like do you
want to make video games and do awesome
stupid computers and you're like yes i
do
she's like come right with me and the
next thing you know you're you're in it
yeah that's like i got to yeah
so yeah go ahead
i break away from college and i get into
the workforce
did stuff i was i started going to
hawking college for electronics
because i wanted to try to get a degree
and while i was there i was basically
told by my landlord
aka my parents you need to get a job
freeloader that's not nice but i
you know they were right so i applied at
best buy
because one of my friends worked there
friends from hawking college worked
there and he's like dude
we can make like 7.75 and all you got to
do is stock shelves
now time minimum wage was 5.15
so 775 was like a king's ransom
um so i go to apply
and you're supposed to list your
experience and i mean i'm a
kid like 19 when i applied there so i
didn't have a whole lot of experience i
thought you
like i worked at this restaurant and i'm
going to college
taking electronics and the gm saw that
he goes
electronics so like computers i'm like
yeah
he's like do you know how to work on
computers i'm like i do i was actually
working on computers on the side just to
bring in some income
he's like how would you like to work for
the tech bench
well now 19 year old me is like holy
crap i can fix computers and make seven
dollars and 75 cents an hour that's a
king's ransom
i'm like you know you consider it like
what's it like he's like well the
starting pay is 905.
i'm like hot damn nice i'm gonna buy a
yacht
yeah with that perspective it it sounds
like a
of course like present day doesn't sound
like a lot but no with that perspective
it sounds
like it like a juicy landing exactly so
here we go
start on the tech bench doing work and
i'm going to ramble a little bit less
i'll move the story along
sure yeah best buy with me
and i thought that was great like super
fun yeah and just to like
kind of go back to something that i
think is really important and
and something that i kind of preach on
my channel
to kind of give a dichotomy from like a
lot a lot of stuff you see on other
channels
there's a lot of channels that say like
never go into the workforce the
workforce sucks
uh don't trust anybody don't trust
people at work that kind of thing you
see that a lot
and that hasn't been my experience and
earlier you said
it was about maintaining relationships
and
basically being cool with people that
helped you get along this far and that's
been my experience too
but when i watch a lot of other
youtubers about this kind of thing
they're often like how you
people at work aren't your friends you
go there you work
and then you leave when it's time and
and stuff like that
and that hasn't been my experience i'm
sure it's true for some people
but i just think it's interesting that
you also kind of have the same
experience of
hey yes be cool with people because
it'll come back to bite you
if you're not basically so i
fundamentally disagree
with the viewpoint that is being
presented where
everybody in the workforce is out to get
you you know like you're on your own
that's a thing and that was honestly
that was a thing when we were looking
for jobs like the
you were starting to see the rise of the
change jobs every like
five years if you want to stay ahead in
the workforce
and to that i would just say what's your
what's your goal
in life like and that that might be hard
to answer when you're 20.
sure because your goals will change or
you know they should as you change as a
person your
your strategy for how you deal with life
could change
i wanted to make a lot of money when i
was young i remember looking for jobs
and the only criteria is does it make
more than what i make now
if the answer was yes the next question
was does it make a lot more
like that's all i cared about
get to a point though or at least i have
where salary is i mean i'm only looking
at like a five percent salary increase
if i if i leave my company
i'll make up numbers that might be like
another ten thousand dollars a year
when you make twenty thousand dollars a
year and you're going up to thirty
that's enormous
right but when you're going from we'll
say a little bit more than that
you get up to i'm just gonna make up
numbers two hundred thousand dollars a
year
you know 220 to 200 is you're already
there
you start thinking about other facets
like how flexible is this job
is this job going to just suck my soul
out right yeah that's that's the big
thing
because it's it's not to say that there
are bad jobs out there
you do i think yeah i've had the same
experience it's more about
having like a healthy job than it is the
amount
after a while and i kind of did have the
same experience in my 20s i was always
like
how much does it pay i'll show up just
how much does it pay
and then at some point it was like how
happy am i going to be here
what are the people like here one you
know i don't want to
sound offensive to the younger
generation but i think your priorities
are different when you're 20 and when
then when you're 40.
when you're 20 you go to your crappy job
and
on the weekends you go get [ __ ] up
like
that's what you do and i'm stealing a
little bit from a rob schneider comedy
skit but like once you get 40 and 50 and
you start to get older
it's like i don't want to go get [ __ ]
up on the weekends anymore because i
only feel good like two days a month
like
i want to i want to feel good on the
weekends um
all that from his comedy skit i thought
it was hilarious because it's true
the the thing that i would i guess i
would recommend is look for a place that
has a healthy
work life balance now a lot of places
say they do
check them like talk to the people that
work there before you get a job you
like young people realize that you're
allowed to ask questions in an interview
and the question should be more than
like what is your company's mission
statement right
you can read like it should be on their
website somewhere
but just ask the people like is this a
cool place to work
like i think i'm pretty cool are you
cool do you have fun here
like are your teammates all right and if
they struggle to answer those questions
that should be a red flag to you like
why like you've got an open position is
it because you scared somebody off like
right yeah i think these are important
things that
yeah people should definitely realize
they can
they're allowed to ask because i yeah i
think a lot of
young people they'll just kind of show
up to an interview
and want to present themselves as well
as possible
and so they'll kind of steer away from
more controversial questions
that are you know just more direct
like that it's
i take for granted that i'm somewhat of
an outgoing person
i like vulnerability i like to talk
about my struggles i
that to me it's a lot better than
bottling them up all right everybody's
that way
not everybody is that way but it like
when they're like
you know tell us about a time that you
were really challenged at work it's like
okay i got like 15 of those which one do
you want that's how
yeah and that's like the interview
question that comes up in every single
interview well it people feel like you
have to have this perfectly polished
answer like
no if if you have a job that requires
absolutely no challenge or thought and
that you can do on autopilot
then you're doing yourself a disservice
in my humble opinion
like if your job is that easy then it
could potentially be replaced by a
machine
like do something that requires thought
and is difficult and is challenging
maybe not all the time but it there
should be periods where you're like this
is really hard and then when you get it
done you're like
freaking a i i did that that's cool i
agree here's
here's what i have to show for that
whether it's a new program that you
developed or
i have to figure out how to get 500
machines out of this physical data
center
into another one on the other side of
columbus and i'm not allowed to turn
them off
that's quite a challenge we moved them
over the internet while they were on
like there's some technologies that make
that possible and it's much easier to do
now but
there's cool there's cool things that
people can do just
push yourself all right i'm off my
soapbox about that oh that was that was
good i think that's
an actually a rather important rant and
uh
yeah about the whole one
okay i guess i was going to say
i don't i kind of lost my train of
thought sorry go ahead
the reason i bring that up is just when
people tell you
ask you when you've messed up just tell
them like i've got one
i actually i brought our my franklin
database down in the middle of the day
uh what that means is that any student
trying to go to the franklin.edu webpage
to like log in to their classes or
register for classes or do anything on
the franklin website
done and that's stressful because when
you're an i.t
you don't want to bring things down your
job is to keep them up right
and that happens and i realize it
happens to go
i start i tell my team like it's down
i'm working on bringing it back up
um there you go you're covering tell the
team take responsibility that's that's
big because
no one ex i don't think anyone expects
anyone to be perfect but they do expect
you to like be honest basically about
what's going on because
you can work with that you know what's
going on you'd be like okay
i see all right let's let's help you
kind of thing
but if they don't know that if you like
keep it bottled up and try to hide it
then they're like
uh maybe we need to get rid of this guy
it erodes everybody's trust in you
yes it's like well if you're not if
you're not honest about a
an outage that we should know about what
else are you not saying like
it's it's it's a weird person thing
there you go
so yeah systems down and in the middle
of trying to fix it i've got a network
architect on my shoulder
and i've got my colleague kind of behind
me just asking questions they're trying
to be helpful
but they're a little too close i'm just
like shoot i don't need your
noise right now and then in the middle
of all this the cio of the company walks
by in his suit and he stops and he looks
he goes
lots of engineers at one desk you guys
break something
and in a i just locked up because i
didn't know what to say like
i wasn't afraid to say i broke this but
i didn't know how to word it because he
just caught me off guard i went uh
yeah and then the network architect on
my shoulder goes
we do have an outage something's down
right now but we're working on bringing
it up we'll email everybody once it's up
he goes
okay and keeps walking all of a sudden
i'm like you can pull up a chair beside
me if you want jiminy cricket you're
welcome to stay as long as you need nice
that's the stories i like to hear like
people that got each other's backs
and and not in the way that they're
gonna like cover with a lie but it's
like
when you yeah you lock up because you're
not sure what to say in the moment but
you're working on it but someone else is
you know clicks for them
um seeing the time i want to finish how
i got where i am
back at best buy sure um i got an
employee that was brought under me
called uh his name was dustin
and i had no say in him getting hired he
was on the computer sales floor and then
one day the managers walked up they're
like oh yeah you got a new guy i'm like
well would have been nice to ask him
some questions like do you know how to
fix things
you know just basic questions
i meet dustin and dustin's real cool
like he worked in other departments of
the store as i mentioned so we got along
okay
and the first day that we were there
together it was me and him
it was his first day closing i actually
almost got fired from the company
because i stayed over to help him close
now best buy this was a big deal because
they were always trying to keep
employees right at 40 hours they didn't
want you to go over well i was a
supervisor at this point
over dustin it was his first day and he
did not know how to close the department
so you had no choice well i i did
a skeptic might say well why didn't you
tell the managers early in the day
that's that's a fair point i did twice
i was scheduled to work 12 to 9 and i
work i was 12 i saw the schedule i'm
like ooh
went back and hey we got a problem we
got a fng
and he's closing by himself he doesn't
have keys to lock up
he doesn't know the process we need to
either get him some help
or i can stay late and show him whatever
you want
like oh it's fine we'll take care of it
just carry on
little slave all right sure go back to
the tech bench do my thing
then again at 6 pm i went i found a new
manager on duty and i'm like hey
here's a problem talked to it earlier
still no dice
need to fix this uh yeah we'll take a
look at that
nine o'clock rolls around we're seven
deep customers
all of them had computers that they
needed um it was called system
customization
they do new sale basically you optimize
the computer
and there's we did a lot of stuff keep
it simple
i'm supposed to go clock out i just look
at the line i'm like nope
i said dustin you check these people out
i'll do all the customizations we'll get
them done we'll get them out of here and
then i'll help you close
the act of me staying over to help him
put me directly on what's called final
warning
at best buy um best buy had a system at
the time where you had
three warnings you had like a verbal
warning a written warning
final warning and if you messed up again
within 90 days
you were fired further sop the only way
you could get put directly on final
warning
with no prior offenses is if you were
involved in a sexual harassment
like infraction well i had not and i had
no prior record and they put me directly
on final warning because they broke
they wrote me up for every um
every possible thing you can write
someone up for attendance
insubordination each one of the boxes
were checked
so they they use that as justification
to try to fire me
i see and you know um this is kind of an
aside but
the management there was notably not
very good
and i think that's kind of a a trend
with best buy from what i understand
i've heard
other stories that aren't so great about
them that's not related to
us or anything i have no comment on that
i honestly don't know
i just know that the the hand that i was
dealt at the time was not awesome
but dustin watched me get in trouble and
he
felt bad he came to me he's like dude
i'm sorry i'm like dude it's not you
like nothing to do with you we're good
and i meant that like i wasn't trying to
play nice like i
had zero qualm with him so fast forward
i
i quit best buy eventually i just got
tired of crying on my lunch breaks
true story um damn that's rough and i
move on
uh i got a job at radio shack and i was
just
selling batteries and resistors on cell
phones oh radio shack
and dustin came back and found me months
later and he goes dude what are you
doing in here
i'm like i don't know man i'm just
working
he's like i want you to come work with
me at a place up in dublin
uh i think you'll like it a lot more i
said yeah man i'll think about it
i was at a pretty low point like
self-esteem wise because
i ended up getting evicted from my
apartment i lost a bunch of stuff
so you talk about trials yeah that was a
thing i think at the time i had
i had an apartment and i moved back in
with my parents
blah blah blah boohoo i apply at this
place in
dublin at dustin's employer and i get
the job
and i go from making seven dollars an
hour at radio shack
to 1536 an hour
at this company that's a lot more
yeah and the only way i ever would have
found that job
was through dustin telling me like hey
try to apply here
at the time i was living in nelsonville
which for those of you not familiar with
the ohio landscape
i was more than an hour away from my job
that i applied for in dublin
and that situation may have never
happened
if the whole thing earlier best buy you
could wrote up for having his back never
happened
so kind of doing the right thing at the
moment was
he saw that it's like okay
that's the thing that kind of goes
against the whole grain of like
look out for yourself your work your
workmates are trash or whatever the
whatever their sayings are yeah i don't
know i mean
there's some truth to it like people
beat you down
like you're still a human being you
still have rights like if somebody's
just being an awful person to you
get away from them and get away from all
of them if you have to like
take care of yourself but don't be an
[ __ ] while you're doing it
that's that's probably the catchphrase
here
uh i know we're out of time we could
we could either do a round two at a
later time because i feel like there's a
lot more
we could say um this is this is proving
to be very fun for me
so okay cool sign me up sure maybe
um we could just continue tomorrow or
something and we'll
pass it all together okay
cool all right well we'll see you
tomorrow or for the viewers it'll be
see in like two seconds because it'll
just be a cut i'll wear the same shirt
i you know i can probably do that too i
hopefully i'll get this
camera thing fixed a little because it's
the way it's set it was not intentional
just making new here yeah right on it's
a little weird with the
virtual camera yeah it's all good yeah
okay let's [ __ ] to a podcast and then
they'll just listen
and this will be like ear porn it'll be
fantastic
okay we're back for day two
i didn't wear the same shirt i just went
and threw this on
because i just figured why not but fair
enough
okay so yeah we might have a little
break in uh
the story here because it's been a
couple days
but uh yeah let's continue your your
story i've got
plenty of things written down for
if we get uh stuck or anything but i
believe you were just saying that
your friend had helped you find a new
job up
and uh somewhere but uh and also
what year are we in approximately just
for contacts
okay uh working with you at best buy
we were 2004 to 2006
and i think i started at the job that i
went with dustin which was a
little company called intravent
i think that was october of 2006. okay
during the
2006 was like a transition year like
trying to recover from best buy and then
moving to dublin for employment anyway
yeah okay
so we don't have to be like super
specific with
locations and all that it's up to you
how comfortable you are with it but
i don't care uh fair enough i don't
really either but yeah just want to keep
you
comfortable with everything
so i end up getting the job working with
this person that had kind of worked
under me at best buy
and we were on roughly an equal footing
here at this job
and that was fine that didn't bother me
um
i worked there until they shut the place
down
um that was 2008
it was february of 2008 february 26th
um i remember they just called us all
into a room
and impromptu company meeting like
managers are like what's going on
and we had been acquired by a
like a parent company and as part of
that
our company was started i was like
employee number 43
so it wasn't a huge company at all there
were two owners
and they sold out to like a parent
company who was much bigger
and as part of the contract like you
can't
you can't close the company down like
you can't just
shut us down and parent companies like
yeah yeah of course
uh well what they did was they they let
go of the president of the company
just got rid of him and the salesman who
was the other
core company employee he stayed around
and made a lot of money off of this
they bring us into a room set us down
and they do a four slide powerpoint
presentation
and it's slide one parent company logo
slide two everybody's terminated on this
day
which was about 90 days from february
26th
slide three except for these six
employees
the developers because it was an
in-house software solution that we did
then slide four was have a good day
contact hr if you have any questions
and they actually had a little sun and
like sunshine and a smiley face on the
slide it's like what the [ __ ]
but they did give you you 90 days yes
that's something at least it wasn't
immediate yeah in hindsight i'm really
glad they did that
what i i often hear you know this
the worst of the stories it's like uh we
had no notice we got let go
yep and i remember this is kind of a
random thing but
i remember you helped me get an
interview there once because i was
looking
for something and i made the worst
impression ever
and i was like holy crap well
i didn't get the job of course did you
show up an hour late
was that it was it was it was something
it was pretty bad i and i think i don't
have a good excuse i don't even remember
what it was
i think i legit overslept and set my
alarm wrong or something
but anyway all terrible excuses
uh i kind of lessons learned i i showed
up anyway
but i knew just going in i was like this
there's no chance of getting hired but
i'll do my best and yeah just
learn from the experience you know but
oh i felt terrible especially that you
like referenced me and that
like uh not not my shiny
moment geez and i i don't want to flip
this and make it
all about you or anything but i feel
like this is worth mentioning
the reason that i continued to recommend
you i knew
that when it came to like showing up to
places on time
that was not at that time in your life
that was not where you shined
no i was terrible about it in my 20s but
you did really good work
and you were fun to work with and you
weren't difficult with managers like
you had a lot of really good things
going for you so i'm like maybe
if he rolls the dice that he shows up on
time it'll be fine
and it's going to work today and that's
okay
because we're here now yeah yeah things
are good now
all right um so that that was back in
the day i don't know if you want to like
continue your story
i guess we were kind of working up to
present day yeah and we can continue
that as as much as you're
comfortable we're trying to go a little
bit faster because i'm
sure we'll be here for a thousand years
i'm going right yeah
um it's just a long lot of years
to come and it's yeah it's my entire
career
like right and well downs here there
sure yeah that's
i mean you're welcome to go into as much
detail as you want but uh
i don't think it's totally relevant
because like the main thing i want to
get out of this is like your current
position really
but how you got to it's definitely
important too
so
get laid off and i just take a help desk
position for
a company that was a healthcare like a
pharmacy
provider called omnicare
and i worked on the help desk and i did
help desk stuff
and i i worked there for a while and i
tried to do a good job
i ended up volunteering to work for a
storage administrator
which was somebody who handles
provisioning data storage to
servers bigger companies that's
important because
you don't have 500 computers with you
know discs in each one of them
like that's expensive it takes up a lot
of space
and it contributes to what's called a
like storage
silos like one server might have
terabytes of
room and another server might be
starving to death
you're like what if you could take all
of the disks and put them in a single
location
and then just give people what they need
it's like it's brilliant and the storage
array was born
i volunteer for just doing some
low-level grunt work for this data
storage guy and we got along pretty good
and then a storage position opened up
and i applied
i did not get it um it got handed to
another employee who i guess
just he did a really good job in the
interview he showed up ready to
take names he had done a lot of research
about storage and
all the changes that this guy had ever
done and i showed up and
he's like do you have any references i'm
like yes
you like i've worked with you for three
months
and you either want to work with me or
you don't and he thought that was really
funny he's like that's a
that's a really good point unfortunately
the person who was offered the position
failed their background check
i think and not only did he not get the
job but they fired him
oh because it was like something they
didn't know
i i yes like i want to keep that part a
little vague but oh yeah definitely
it's nothing it's nothing inappropriate
or bad the person just
didn't have a license and they were
driving without a license
oh okay and i there are remembrances but
yes still i remember at the time i'm
like so you you straight fire the dude
because
i mean he shows up he does a good job at
his job like
but they're like not liability gone and
he ended up suing the company and
winning
like a class-action lawsuit like this
isn't right and
he won right yeah right so it didn't
sound right
no it's terrible this was not a great
place to work
in his absence like i remember
i knew i didn't get the job because
there were four of us that had applied
and we were all talking to each other
constantly like you heard anything have
you heard anything
these are my friends on the help desk
and then one guy gets real quiet all of
a sudden
and we start seeing a little bit less of
him it's like he got the job
and that's okay you know that's life
well then he's just gone
it's like well maybe he didn't get the
job
well meanwhile i had applied at another
place where that dustin guy the same
dustin
was working and i actually got the job
they're like here man here's your offer
letter it was a five dollar an hour pay
cut though
which i wasn't thrilled about but i was
contract at the time so this would have
been full time
and that's a big deal because there's
benefits and blah blah blah oh yeah sure
that more than makes up for the five
dollars an hour probably
so on my way back to the company
i was talking on the phone i'm like to
my dad i'm like what do you think like
yes no he's like well sounds like it
might work whatever irrelevant
i get to work and i get pulled into a
meeting and they're like uh we want to
give you the storage administrator job
and here it is and it's a five dollar an
hour pay raise
and full time i'm like yeah sign me up
i went from contractor to full time and
got a huge raise like
living the life okay so was this at your
current
place or the place before a place right
before okay
gotcha it was at this place this
omnicare place that i started to learn
data storage
and what being an i.t system
administrator was like
i got introduced to like the politics
and budgeting and like
trying to break fix stuff when it's
broken and just all of that normal
i.t sysadmin life and i'm about
24 when all this is going on
so like i'm cool i'm reliable but i'm
still kind of young
yeah fast forward to where i'm at now
um i got kind of miserable working there
there was a lot of management changes
and i just started to hate my job like i
know a lot of people hate their job but
like there's a point where you're just
miserable
like every moment you're there you just
want to be somewhere else
and you you never want to go and like
this takes up a lot of my life
yeah i don't necessarily want to be like
super happy
all the time i just want to be like
super not unhappy
like yeah
i see and i apply at franklin
university which is where i work now
franklin university um yeah
and i i end up getting the job there
that's one of the first jobs where i
felt like i walked in
and i knew enough to where i could be
pretty confident
a lot of my jobs up to this point were
because i knew somebody
or i had like i made the person laugh in
the interview
like it wasn't because i felt like i was
amazing because
and i to be fair i don't now but it i at
least had enough credit to where i could
sit down and interview
sensibly they ask questions and i can
give answers
um then i show up at franklin
cool i started at franklin doing storage
which was what i did at omnicare but now
i'm doing like storage and responsible
for a virtualization stack
so i handle basically everything above
networking
and below operating system so
provisioning servers
the storage forum backing them up
disaster recovery
all of that stuff is under my purview
okay
that's interesting uh so i have some
things kind of listed here
just to kind of ask you that i think
people will be interested in
sure
okay so like how much does
programming come up i know you kind of
mentioned he wrote scripts sometimes
often to kind of save uh
in case you couldn't get a tool or
something you would often just handle it
with a script how much of your
life have you simplified with these
scripts and what do you
usually use is it just batch scripts or
is it linux
a lot of questions there i'll pick them
apart yeah sure however you want to do
it
so i'll answer your last question first
i use
shell scripts i've done a little bit in
perl
i primarily use powershell just because
it ties in really well to the
applications that i use
gotcha um i mentioned before that
i the the tools that i'm trying to write
or the jobs that i'm trying to
accomplish
are basically if only i had money i
would buy a tool
to extract data from an app well i don't
have the money
but the data is still in the app so i
just need to figure out how to get it
out
and powershell has a lot of um
commandlets that tie into
specific applications and it makes it
i don't want to say easy but it makes it
possible
to just go through and pick through it
and start getting it out and
massaging it the way you need and how
did you learn these did you
were you did someone like give you a
course
or a hands-on training or did you just
kind of figure it out as you went
the way that i did it i got my
bachelor's degree from franklin
university
and we took a little bit of programming
classes
but it wasn't your classic like here's
java here's c
plus here's javascript
it was like here's powershell here's
perl and they were part of operating
system administration classes
so i mean it was a very quick here's how
to write a very basic program in perl
here's okay write a very basic program
in powershell
just to do something gotcha and what was
your degree in
it that had those courses that was
information technology
okay yep see i didn't have anything like
that with computer science it was like
yep straight to to memory and
programming
and all the it stuff was pretty much
left out and i
i wonder sometimes if i should have just
done a computer science degree
because more and more of my job is
about creating things and processes to
do things efficiently
and cheaply and i've actually
considered going back and getting a
subsequent bachelor's in just
computer science just because it'll
force me to go through programming
languages and get better at them
sure sure yeah there's definitely a lot
you can learn online
too and uh you know my mate one c plus
plus so if you ever get
into that i'd be happy to sit down with
you and play around
with whatever you're working on or right
up you know i don't i don't want to
derail the conversation but my love is
definitely programming and i
but i get it i kind of like the the
scripting stuff too it's pretty useful
for sure yep
okay so how was how was life with remote
doing all this when covet was going on
honestly not that bad it's been pretty
awesome
um most of my job is about
connecting to remote things and doing
stuff on them
okay so the ad person is pretty rare
anyways you my customers usually come
through
tickets i do manage virtual labs at
franklin university
also so i'll have students that are
having trouble with a course
and it's hey my router's not working
and you know we're not allowed to give
them answers so we always have to walk
the line
to figure out what's going on and then
it's like well
check the config of your router because
the way that it's configured it's not
going to do what you need it to do
maybe check steps one through five of
lab one
for some inspiration and they're like
okay i got it thanks and
um so those can come in no matter where
i'm at
i can be at work you know on campus or i
can be in my basement
i can i still have access to our
ticketing system uh
my work employs a lot of instant
messaging tools and email and all that
works everywhere
actually i can do a lot of my job from
my phone nice
i set up a remote desktop app on that
connects to my computer and then from
there i just hop on vpn and
do it all that's cool i have that set up
for our
game servers that i occasionally host
being able to access from anywhere
really comes in handy
yes it does did you did you have
anything new
were you like did you kind of have all
this remote stuff prepared anyway before
covert or ready to get it set up
after you figure it out so i had it all
prepared before
okay i can remember the friday
when we had a discussion about basically
switching to remote because my team's a
technical infrastructure team so we're
part of that you know like the network
team is my sister team
or brother team like a sibling team
we just said can our vpn concentrator
handle the entire university traffic all
at once
and the answer was maybe so what we did
was we configured what's called a split
tunnel vpn
that's where work traffic is forced
through the vpn and all other traffic
just goes through the regular web
browser outside of the vpn
okay that way people can youtube in
peace and not
bog the university resources down gotcha
i remember when i was working at uh ohio
university we had a problem where too
many people were watching netflix
and it was bogging down everything it
that is a real problem
i don't believe that was i i don't blame
ohio university for that because we had
urbana university which was a second
college that we owned
from like 2014 to 2020.
um unfortunately due to kovid um
it's not here anymore that's a whole
other story
i'm i'm just a messenger like awkward
but urbana was a traditional university
that had
students you know dorms playstations
xboxes youtube all that
netflix we had to configure qos
because they would they would netflix so
hard that it would just fill up the pipe
i think that's what we ended up doing
too yeah but that was
a severe qos it's like yeah you're not
going to get awesome frame rates on this
sorry all right got to do what you gotta
do
it's not like they need it for their
classes
i guess you know i don't know that's
where it gets interesting because
research documentation or documentaries
and stuff
historically franklin has always been
hesitant to avoid
like do any kind of blocking towards
youtube because
people do look at academic things on
youtube
like videos and trainings and sure yeah
they can't just shut it down um
now of course there's people that abuse
it as well that's
a whole other thing right
um okay uh so do you what kind of advice
do you have for
someone else that might be looking to go
towards your type of career
we've probably already touched on a lot
of that but i have that written down
so sure
i would say
spend time making a plan on what you
think you want to do
and don't be afraid to try different
things if what you're
you're working in isn't cutting it for
you
i remember when i was younger i was all
about chasing the dollar i think we
talked about this last time
and as i've got older i just i want to
do a good job while i'm at work i want
to help the people that i'm supposed to
help but when i'm not at work i want to
spend time with my friends my family
like my hobbies i don't want to be
miserable all the time
and we spend a lot of time at work like
we spend a lot of time at work we spend
almost
as much time or more time with our work
people than we do our own families
sure so don't settle for a place that
sucks
and i'm not trying to two franklin
university's horn but they are fantastic
the people i work with they're amazing
like i really i do i like all of them so
the shift from your previous job to this
one
just night and day difference i remember
i was so bitter when i left the other
place
that as i was talking to hr getting the
offer letter
and they were talking about perks and
benefits of the job
she actually said something like and
blah blah blah
we do performance bonuses i just i'm
like oh yeah yeah that's that's pretty
good
because my last place did performance
bonuses as well but we never saw
them
and she's like no i'm serious i've been
here for x years and i have always got
one
i'm like oh is that right how does that
work and she explained it and it's it's
a real thing
like so naturally you're skeptical from
the previous experience
yeah you get you get jaded because
sometimes people they promise the world
and then they don't deliver
anything close to it and i guess that's
another thing i would say for advice
if somebody offers you something and it
sounds too good to be true ask
questions makes sense
like you say here blah blah blah like
can you elaborate on that what does that
mean
based on what it says could i expect
this oh no that's that's not it at all
ah okay thanks i'm glad we had this
conversation because now i don't want to
work here or whatever your
your knowledge may vary yeah definitely
makes sense to get clarity
especially if it's something like
performance bonuses
what kind of performance you know i
imagine i'd have questions too
but that's good because a lot of people
will just nod along and will think
good enough but they won't really know
what it means so
i think it's definitely valuable to ask
questions
another thing that is interesting to
watch is how companies handle
like the hard times like maybe they have
a few quarters or a few years where
things aren't going real great
yeah like what's their solution if their
solution is to chop
people first you got to wonder about
that because you're losing tribal
knowledge
in addition to the work it takes to
retrain replacements
i like i like the word tribal knowledge
well that's exactly what it is it's like
i know how things work because i've been
here for a while right
i know that on wednesdays at two o'clock
that door is going to open and there's
going to be somebody coming through
needing something or you know something
random
yeah you just you figure it out and it's
hard to put that on paper but it's
useful
especially in the business process like
understanding how business works in your
place
and this manager tends to like things
presented in this format
those are invaluable resources
definitely i think we called that
institutional knowledge
at uh you which sounds way
more sophisticated than you know me like
i'm running around throwing coconuts and
people or something maybe it's because
we played a bunch of valheim
all right i got one that's a little less
work related
so yeah i know you do jujitsu you're
always talking about it
and been in that world has that affected
your work or
i don't know i guess i just kind of want
to hear
you talk about that a little bit okay
so it has it affected my work yes
absolutely
um when you break bones it's harder to
type
who knew i'm kidding have you had to
take
time off of work from some injuries
short answer yes longer answer
both from and not from jiu jitsu um
i've had four surgeries in the past six
years my body kind of sucks
myself i was actually i had a problem
with my neck
and i was out of franklin for eight
weeks
i took eight weeks continuous off and
they gave me short-term disability which
covered my salary
my boss was great my co-workers were my
co-workers actually came and visited me
once like for lunch they picked me up um
that's that's a big deal that's super
cool
yeah because i wasn't allowed to leave
like my neck was literally reforming
like they had to take bones out and put
new bones in like it was it was a treat
wow so back to jiu jitsu um
i do brazilian jiu jitsu i've done it
for about i think april will be five
years
so two months from or next month
actually will be five years
the thing about jiu jitsu is it teaches
perseverance
and growth through discomfort
in jiu jitsu you fail at things you try
to do something to someone and it
doesn't
work and when it doesn't work it has a
really bad result usually you're flat on
your back with somebody on top of you
that's not a fun place to be
gotcha and they get you in some kind of
hole or something oh yeah it
it very rarely does it get better what's
your
at least at my level um but one of the
things you learn is just
there's gr there's beauty and some
suffering like
and you see it a lot in in a project at
work i'll
case in point i just got done upgrading
a
or creating a process to automate data
collection
so that i can trend how much of our
backup storage we're using
at any given time and it shows a nice
little sine wave
of like you know this time of the month
it's high then it's low and
blah blah blah and i was really proud of
myself it took forever but i got it
working
and everything was automated and i
upgraded my backup environment and i
broke all of it
it doesn't work at all this was last
friday so today is wednesday
this was four days ago and i was
so frustrated i'm like oh god i worked
for two months on this
so now i have to figure out like i'm
either going to rebuild it
or i'm going to build a new way to do it
i
i still need to get it done and i you
know i kind of got my shoulders
flat on the mat now i got to crawl out
and do it again
is that something that like uh your boss
asked you to do or anything like that or
was it just like
i would really like to have this kind of
thing
unfortunately it was the former um okay
the performance bonuses i talked about
are based on goals
and i do a manual like data collection
on
our usage and my boss is like you know
i'd really like it if you could automate
that
so that i could see it at any time i
said okay sounds good i'll get to work
cool and i got it the end of the period
was july
or is july so i'm like it's march nailed
it
and then i broke it all i'm like well
still got still got some time
uh that's interesting war stories
all right do you happen to have any
secret tips about this field that people
may not know not necessarily secret but
like
you know just things that the average
person wouldn't necessarily know until
they were deep in it
what if not that's fine it's no it's i'm
trying to figure out how to work
try to ramble for 20 minutes okay okay
in my career i have often been
responsible for a lot of things at once
meaning like we used to have a
four-person team and now we're down to
two people because you know people have
moved on
and they just didn't fill the positions
i have i have a lot that i'm supposed to
keep track of
don't let that be an excuse to not have
expertise in the things that you manage
because being ignorant of
how something works is not a not an
excuse
to end up making big mistakes especially
now we live in an
era where if you want to know anything
about anything
just go on the internet and read
go to a forum ask questions
you'll find people that are really
bright and very good at sharing
information
i would say that those people are a
little bit rare because sometimes people
are very bright and they're just
mean stack overflow tfm noob
i'm i'm trying to rtfm i don't
understand tfm that's why i'm asking
questions
but you'll find people that they can
break concepts down and explain it to
you
and that that
it returns dividends like i just did a
meeting today where somebody was trying
to pitch a
a replacement you know product solution
to me
and it didn't pass my sniff test and as
i started asking questions and picking
it apart they're just like
wow you really know what you're talking
about on this i'm like
yeah like if i'm gonna if i'm gonna ask
the university to spend money on this
i need to understand it i need to be the
person who can say
i have looked into this i've spent a lot
of freaking time reading about it
i've asked questions i've done demos
like i get it and i'm
confident if we bought it it would work
don't guess on stuff like that because
those are costly mistakes
that's a good one i like it
yeah my list is pretty much over i have
i guess one more thing that's pretty
unrelated to uh
i guess it's kind of it's related to
work advancement
so for the audience josh and i were kind
of having a
conversation about calling
the calling list not you know call with
a u
about kind of uh just tightening the
inner circle a little bit
as a way to you know make sure your life
is like on the right track and
you don't have the wrong people kind of
weighing you down or something
it's kind of hard to explain but
we had some interesting conversations
just between us totally offline so
i don't know i just think that's
something other people might be
interested in uh hearing a little bit
because
it's inevitable that uh pretty much
everybody
has someone in their life that's
hard to deal with and it's how do you
make the call of who you can help
and who you can't
it's
everybody's allowed to have a bad day
sure yeah and
some people's bad days are really really
bad days
like they go through something that's
just awful
i am of the humble opinion that
you start to notice people that have
more bad days than good days
and no matter what it's always a bad day
and they can tell you why it's a bad day
but they can't tell you how they're
going to get through the bad day
it's just they're drowning and they
refuse to
to maybe take a you know take a buoy
sure case in point i had a friend who
was having some financial trouble and we
sat down and made a budget
and later on that friend starts having
financial trouble again
and i asked if they wanted to review the
budget
and then the friend was having trouble
again and it's just like
i want to be helpful
for you but i i don't know what else to
do
because this is a pattern
and maybe maybe you're gonna have to
feel the burn for a little while
to understand why you're in the pattern
i
i don't know i'm not i'm not a life
coach or anything like that but it
like you said everybody knows someone
who's got it's just that
it's like they're trying to run and
their shoes or shoelaces are tied
together they just keep falling flat on
their face
sure and you're like untie your
shoelaces and they're like nah it's good
they just keep falling that's a good
analogy
i like that analogy yeah that's i'm of
about the same opinion
it's for me it's i'll definitely try to
help people
several times but once i see the pattern
of
they don't want help they just want
handouts
yes that's when it's different it's like
if you're trying to
get through things and trying then yeah
i'd love to help i want to see you
succeed
but at some point it's like if if you
don't necessarily want to succeed and
you just kind of want to use people
i'm not that person i'm not the person
to be used you know
sure and i want to be really careful
here because i i want to avoid the
the notion that we're you know we're
pedestaling ourselves or anything
right yeah it's not like that it's
i think this is just in general anyone
who's trying to do anything important
with their life
or raise a family successfully even
you just gotta be careful about
who you kind of let into your life
sometimes and that's i don't think
that's
necessarily put on a pedestal it's you
just need to protect people you care
about including yourself
one thing that always stands out to me
is people talk about needing help with
money you know like i
don't have enough money to pay my bills
and like all right
but you you follow them either through a
text message or a facebook or whatever
it may be
yeah and as you do that for a couple of
years you're like
you've been on an awful lot of vacations
you drive a car that's nicer than mine
your cell phone is a flagship
phone i mean have you ever considered
that maybe your lifestyle is
contributing to your problem
just a thought yeah that's kind of
that's a very american problem oh yes
because people it's so easy to get
credit and get loans and
go to rent a center and get a nice tv
and just take pictures of it
i always find that a bit strange i was
talking
with one of my relatives today about our
materialistic society
and the the idea that we like to brag
about
our successes we as a you know a people
yeah so people wanna they buy the big tv
and they put it in their nice house and
they
they flaunt their new car
but those are those are temporary things
all of them are designed to fall apart
so you're going to have to replace them
and maintain them
and it's just you have a finite amount
of money like
understanding that unless you get a
raise or unless you spend less
you always have a finite amount of money
like it's the only way you'll ever
advance get more money or spend less
that's kind of a dave ramsey thing
not trying to steal from him but gotcha
the the idea that
a middle-class person is supposed to
have you know a cell phone and bitchin
fast internet and a nice car
or two and a nice house it's like
build up to that save put money in
savings because you never know when
you'll get freaking laid off
it's happened and i have money put back
for emergencies
because i can't i can't predict the
future
but i can't prepare for it
well said
yeah i guess that's kind of a that's
like a tough topic
and it's hard to say everything right
when that kind of topic but
i'm sure and i mean i can only give my
account
of what i've experienced like i don't
want to offend anybody or anything like
that but right
it's inevitable you know you say no
matter how perfect you say something
there's always going to be
offended people so you can only worry so
much about that kind of thing
but yeah i i'm curious to see what other
people think
about that sort of thing but i feel like
we're probably not too far off base
all right well i guess we could
wrap this up we're kind of at a natural
closing point i feel like do you got any
got anything else uh you can think of
that you might want to
talk about that we haven't touched on
yeah i got one sure going back to
[Laughter]
going back to omnicare age 24 the day
that we got laid off
so i'm a i'm a kid i got jeans on i got
my little rock and roll t-shirt and life
is great
and i go into our break room because we
had a company supplied fridge and like
the company would put like milk and
orange juice and just random crap in
there and i was
always looking for a free meal or like
you know a second breakfast or whatever
mind you i wasn't stealing from other
people's lunches it was just
the company had stuff that you could eat
gotcha yeah yeah
small place and as i walk in i see
there's free burrito coupons on the
table
because we are vip business customers
and there's this burrito place called
baja fresh down the road and they're
just opening
so they're trying to you know get the
word out yeah
so i grabbed me a stack of like 30 of
them
i'm going to give these to my co-workers
and as i'm trotting back to my
co-workers
i get diverted into a meeting room and
then i we all get laid off
and at the end of the powerpoint
slideshow that i talked about
i felt tension in the room because an
entire room full of people just got laid
off
and like there were people that started
to cry there were people that started to
scream
and like i'm not trying to be dramatic
like this this is how it went down and
i'm just like oh this is not good
so wait wait let me just for clarity so
intravet
got closed and you got the 90-day notice
but omnicare got like a
same-day shutdown layoff i'm not sure
with omnicare
because i left omnicare before it closed
this was back at intravet sorry okay
lots of jobs
intravet the day of the 90 day layoff
okay okay this is the meeting that's
going on
thanks for the clarify the guy beside me
starts
like uh what's the word i'm looking for
hyperventilating like he's he's breaking
down like he's
really suffering he's sweating real bad
and i just instinctively the guys like
at the front like do you have any
questions you know like corporate guy
and my hand flies up
and he he looks at me stupid because you
know i got my hand up he's like
you and i hold up the stack of 30
burrito coupons i'm like
hey i got a question uh i just got these
free
vip customer burrito coupons and i was
curious like do you happen to know if
baja fresh will still accept them
because
we just got laid off and the room
explodes with laughter
because this guy's trying to answer a
stupid ass question that nobody should
have asked
yeah you sir are a legend and we all
went to baja fresh
i love that we can wrap this up with the
burrito story
i mean it's just it's perfect you do
realize the pun right
yeah yeah makes it even better
[Laughter]
all right josh thanks for coming on uh
my great pleasure my friend
thank you so so much for watching
don't forget to your application out
there with zeet
every new signup helps the channel
link down below we'll see you next time
here on codetech tutorials
peace
[Music]
you